m
en hommage aux travailleurs engagés de
la réunion s'est déroulée ce vendredi 12
novembre lazaret de la grande chaloupe
lieu de quarantaine obligatoire pour la
plupart des ancêtres venus à la réunion
comme engagé
en fait la manifestation se déroule en
trois temps d'abord nous avons nous
avons effectué un hommage aux ancêtres
face à la mer ensuite on propose au
public donc un temps de parole en
échange entre les différentes
communautés et ensuite pour terminer
nous proposons un temps culturel
on les
visiteurs peuvent eux
venir découvrir nos expositions
découvrir les stands associatifs
la première partie la manifestation
conçue devant la mer à rendre un hommage
aux ancêtres qui sont passés par le
lazaret grande partie et qui sont
ensuite allés vivre sur le territoire et
une belle enrichir la culture
réunionnaise et construire la société de
la réunion telle qu'on la connaît
plusieurs associations culturelles et
cultuelles était réunie ce jour pour cet
hommage mais cérémonie placée sous le
thème du vivre ensemble
c'est un on va dire rappel de l'histoire
qui doit nous aider à comprendre comment
dans la douleur comment dans la
difficulté
ces réunionnais de toutes origines se
sont unis pour créer sa société
réunionnaise est là quand même que
murray cet événement s'est renforcé
notre vivre ensemble
c'est important pour nous parce que vous
savez des hommes et des femmes sont
venues en grand nombre à la réunion sans
racines ici et nous avons tous ils ont
tous ensemble construit l'avenir il a
construit la société réunionnaise
bano aujourd'hui la réunion on va dire
c'est l'exemple même c'est un modèle
comparé aux autres at-il puisqu'on vous
êtes vous on a en a pas de souci
particulier de vivre ensemble à la
réunion une célébration riche en rappel
historique qui a réuni plusieurs
centaines de réunionnais en souvenir de
l'abolition de l'engagisme en 1880 dur